um all right let's go next to mike from
massachusetts mike you're on the air
how are you doing today david i'm doing
well
good to hear um i got two questions if
we can go if we have the time please uh
first and if you've already spoken about
this on your show and i missed it i
apologize for the repetition um what do
you make of
what's going on in
austria with their nationwide mandate
and that other countries in europe are
starting to inch towards doing the same
thing
do you
like a nationwide vaccine mandate i mean
do you see that as simply a step too far
for western democracy or is it kind of
or do you feel like maybe we've reached
a point where the extreme circumstances
will
uh require extreme solutions listen here
here's my view of right uh dire
circumstances require extreme solutions
um my view is is as follows i'm trying
to think about this as pragmatically as
possible
my opinion on this is heavily biased by
the fact that it's not going to happen
in the united states so when someone
says to me do you think it's too far or
not might it happen the united states is
not going to have a literal vaccine
mandate where the government says you
must be vaccinated they're doing stuff
through employers osha
employers must test or
but it's just not going to happen and so
because i see that it's just kind of a
non-starter
it's hard for me to say it would be the
right or the wrong thing necessarily i
mean i think it is morally defensible
at the same time i think there are good
arguments
legally speaking for why it can be a
work requirement it can be a school
requirement it can be a requirement to
avail yourself of certain types of
businesses but just a straight-up
mandate it's i don't know legally
whether it would stand in a completely
broad-based federal way
although there's people on both sides of
that
i think my issue at this point is what
is most likely to most quickly get us
out of the pandemic and by that i mean
to an endemic phase it doesn't seem like
it's going to go away
and um
it is about convincing the people we can
convince to go and get vaccinated
uh and also
to some degree it's about the reality
that we don't interact with everyone
like the fact that there's a big
anti-vaxx community in mississippi
is statistically very unlikely to affect
my exposure to the virus sure i might be
on a plane with folks but for the most
part it's like what's going on in my
kind of more immediate community travel
spreads it etc etc but i'm trying to
focus more on sort of like what can i do
within my immediate community and so to
go back to your question do i think it's
right or wrong what austria is doing i
don't fully know everything that's
taking place in austria
but it's not for me to say that they are
right or wrong for doing it this is what
they're doing i don't think it's going
to happen in the united states so my
concern is how can we get beyond the
pandemic phase given that there's not
going to be a full-on vaccine mandate
that's i'm thinking pragmatically
so i agree with you that it's extremely
unlikely to happen at the federal level
um that would be a very big uphill
battle for any administration to take on
but
do you see
do you see a certain point where maybe
states might try to impose a statewide
vaccine i really don't i really don't
like it
by the supreme court in the past yeah i
know it has and there's this very
important case from cambridge
massachusetts and i think it was 1903
that people point to as precedent i
think that republican governors would
never do it and democratic governors
realize it would be politically
problematic so i don't think we're even
going to see a mandate at the state
level i could be wrong if i'm wrong i'll
eat my socks you know
fair enough um all right switch gears to
a second question i'll just try to keep
things moving
um so this is this might be purely
opinion oriented at this point but so
the supreme court is hearing
the missouri abortion case today at
least is hearing arguments on it
um and i've been here i've been trying
to do my own research and look into what
certain experts think about what is
going to happen and
the opinions are all over the map uh
you know some people think that
this should be so obvious that it's
unconstitutional that the mere fact that
they're hearing it is a bad sign yes um
but then there are you know there are
conservatives who are like the supreme
court always lets us down it's not it's
going to be the same case this time so
and obviously that's not me saying let
down but that's the conservative saying
that they get let down
i mean do you what's your opinion on how
this is all going to shake out i mean
are we looking at the end of roe v wade
or is this going to get shot down and
servers are going to freak out again i
have no idea i really don't i could it's
it's i've read some of the same stuff
you've read it sounds like and i don't
even bother making a prediction because
it's so unclear it's sort of a wacky
supreme court it's strange times i think
anything could happen i do think that if
one of these really strict laws is
upheld by the supreme court it is the
beginning of the end for roe v wade but
as far as what is going to happen i have
no idea we're just gonna have to wait
and see
okay
um fair enough all right thank you for
taking my call all right mike from
massachusetts thank you so much for the
call appreciate everybody we were able
to speak to that's going to do it for
today but we will take calls again soon
and remember december 14th at 6 p.m will
be a wide open viewer town hall
where
everyone is welcome to call in more on
that upcoming